5 12 new tuesday morning a new exhibit
highlighting aviation opening later this
morning at the children's
discovery children's museum in downtown
las vegas and it was put together
in partnership with mccarran airport our
hector mejia live inside the museum to
give our first look this morning
hector you are clear for takeoff go
ahead hacked over here and roger go
over here today for a second i was like
wait
what is that voice in my area i couldn't
recognize her voice but here at the
museum
this part of the exhibit it feels like
we are actually at mccarran
international airport and out there you
can see the backdrop
feels like we're just looking out from
one of the gates waiting to uh take
flight
and off to the right we have some early
morning live action going on
joining us live we have sam nelson here
with the disc discovery children's
museum
to explain the inspiration behind all of
this and all the work that went into uh
putting this together good morning
good morning yeah welcome to our new
reimagined
airport with our sponsorship partnering
with uh mccarran our local international
airport
so the space is awesome and it's pretty
cool it uh
highlights all the different career
pathways that the airport
in town um highlights as well from
piloting to
flight in flight controllers to flight
attendants
to tsa agents anything like that it's
really introducing
new career opportunities for kids
this is pretty cool what we're looking
at now this is a high-tech cockpit for
kids to get some hands-on fun
trying to play pilot and piloting a
plane here
and uh what's going on right now so
right now we have a
our friend killian in there and he's
checking out all the different
instrument panels
and different ways that kids can get a
real hands-on experience
where they may not be able to anywhere
else all right thank you very much well
we'll be back in a little more than half
an hour from now to show you around for
now reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you he has uh
successfully landed
his live shot hector he was cleared for
landing and uh perfectly
look at that so cool wow that is very
cool